Android patterns for performance
One of the most common performance issues
Which your users will notice is the reaction of your app
When you go from a great network connection
To a bad connection.
My name is Colt McCannless.
If your app does not adequately adapt to the network response time of the day,
Your users will app your app instead of connecting.
In fact, the Internet consists of a group of crazy moving parts,
Or a set of pipes if you are a senator.
However, requests sent from your phone must collide with a local cellular tower
Which it then directs to the server of the service provider.
You may then encounter a local data agent of that provider
Before accessing the Internet and connecting to the main data server
Which then needs to decode the response and fetch the data
Then resend it, all just to return the data
To the ISP server for the cache, and then finally to the phone itself.
As you can see, there are lots of moving parts,
A problem may arise at any stage.
Since you do not control all those stages,
The best you can do is make sure that your app adapts correctly
With a device-based way of doing it.
This includes two things:
First, get information about the speed and performance of the network,
Second, design your application to respond to changes
In environments with poor response time.
Unlike your expectations, it is easy to do the first point.
All you have to do is bring the contact manager
And determine whether you are on a mobile network.
From there, with a quick connection to bring the subnet type,
You get an enumeration list for the type of network you are connecting to.
A practical search table shows you which type of network you are using
And what can be expected as the best frequency bands and possible response times.
But in fact, that value gives you the best scenario.
The results are worse in the real world.
Although your LTE user can be used,
A problem may occur because the data server is slow,
Which may lead to a doubling of time
Which the server normally takes on that network for that application.
The most precise solution, despite its great complexity
In estimating the time it takes for the server to bring responses
From your network.
For example, if you learn that all your thumbnails
In displaying your list of dimensions 128 in 128 pixels,
You will have a general sense that the size must be in the alpha
This takes only a certain amount of time to download on a particular network.
You can then estimate the actual average cost of attaching over time
To give you a better overview of real network settings
And how it changes as the user navigates during his or her day.
After obtaining this information,
You need to decide how to design your application to handle the situation.
As a simple approach, you can specify two thresholds
And three containers of classification.
If the response time
Less than a small threshold of 60 milliseconds to bring an origin,
Your user has a great connection.
You may be able to increase the amount of data you prepare in advance
Unlike things like caching.
But if it takes less than the upper threshold,
You may not be in the best position.
So be careful to increase the transmission in batches and buffering
And take advantage of the number of times your request for data.
If they are greater than the maximum threshold,
You should look for ways to postpone your requests until later,
When there is probably better network connectivity,
Or non-user interface
So not bringing all the thumbnails is not a big trouble.
But in fact,
These thresholds will not work for each user.
It will indeed need some effort
To find the correct thresholds
50, 90 and 99 percent
Of the communications your users use.
This is indeed a major engineering project
But it is very important to your application
So that it remains responsive in environments with high response times.
Instead of waiting for users to complain about slow connections,
It is best to start design and test the bad data transfer rate
On your application in advance.
You can test the impact of large response time on your applications
By restricting the data transfer rate when running Android Emulator.
Or you can check the external applications,
Such as AT & T's Network Attenuator.
In both cases, you can follow how your app responds
When response time increases a lot, you should do this with everything, in fact.
The performance test is the slowest hardware
The worst networks and the most insane situations
Is the best way to ensure stable and consistent performance of users.
Of course, watch the other Android Performance Patterns videos
To identify and solve problems.
I invite you to join the Google+ community
For advice from other developers like you.
Your users will definitely thank you.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.